big moment I guess at the State of the
Union last night was a slight heckling
and response moment by the president
let's take a look I have no more
campaigns to run my only agenda I know
because I won both of them
all right so I wanted to play out some
of the applause and then his response
and then the smile after because that
was sort of to me like the best of Obama
actually like he said something the
Republicans went in for the subtle like
I we don't like you and then he nailed
them and then you know everybody
everybody was into it it's a good comedy
move it almost struck me his response
was so quick and so clever that just
from doing comedy it almost struck me
that maybe this was a plant like was
that a Democrat who did that who did
that applause there it did seem to me
like that was either rehearsed or
planned out but he's such a pro at this
point and he's so good at articulating
things when they're kind of just funny
and off-the-cuff that I think it worked
I mean that was the thing that was in my
Twitter feed the most
you know everything else you talked
about people did not care about all you
saw it was like Obama drops the
microphone with this quip so obviously
it worked for him yeah was the irony of
that moment though him saying I don't
have to run anymore so I can try to work
with you and we can do the best we can
in these two years and then the
Republicans who assuming it was a
Republican that applauded that they
immediately were like I you're out of
here [ __ ] and then that he
immediately came back like it actually
showed the real problem of Washington
while I think what he was trying to do
was take the high road in this case you
know and then it immediately devolved
into aa potentially I mean I was
watching that and being like that's
adorable and ya know leader of the free
world probably want to be called
adorable adorable little at the end he's
just like yeah he looks so good I yeah I
I mean I had already a gaffe on national
television talking about how much I love
this president so I'm not gonna let go
that there was an American Idol thing
that happened a while back pretty riot
but there's no I think exactly about him
some very likable and very performative
when he gets up there right yeah as a as
a performer myself and as someone who
appreciates excellent performances I
think that there that's something that
I'll always remember as being
particularly special about him yeah the
same way that Clinton was to a certain
extent but even more so a little bit
yeah so we talked about this a little
bit in the earlier segment but do you
guys think that anyone in the next let's
say 20 years is ever
gonna run on anything as exciting as his
first run because as I said I'm not like
it seems like we were collectively on
drugs and now it's like you're right
he's such a pro and every time even if
I'm frustrated with you know he said the
thing like last night about net
neutrality and he wants the Internet to
be free but he also appointed Tom
wheeler who was a lobbyist for the FCC
to be in charge of it so that's the time
he kept talking about fundraising but
meanwhile how many $32,000 are played
fund raisers as he's done and yet so
he's saying one thing and yet he says it
in a way and or it's in a way that I'm
like each time I keep I keep buying it
for a little bit for a couple of days
after so is that like I feel like the
next president I suppose is gonna have
to be somebody that it's all about
policy like I think the country is gonna
be tired of just a well-spoken guy how
was that was that even a question I
don't know what I did that well I think
it's I think the way all those things
just came out of you is like the exact
same way that all the thoughts are in
our head we're all like wait do we want
another charismatic leader that's gonna
make us all feel good and that we get
really excited and he rallies his base
but also the other side or do we want
someone who comes in and actually gets
things done
yeah what's unfortunate is that you
can't get people to vote for somebody
who's just policy policy policy because
if they said exactly what they're going
to do right for they did it not only
would the other side whether it's
Republicans or Democrats opposed them so
much that they couldn't get it done yeah
but then they wouldn't be exciting no
one wants to get excited about somebody
that's like no one gets excited about
the accountant or the bean-counter or
you know someone who's actually the
lawmaker people get excited about the
charismatic leader of the world yeah so
I totally buy that go ahead here's what
I think we get excited about the first
female run administration right like
that's gonna be the next one where
people are gonna be like hell yes and
you know maybe it's radical maybe it's
not but I think that you know as I try
and build sort of a female heavy media
company as myself yeah there's gonna be
a moment where people are like oh [ __ ]
yes like gender diverse organizations do
run better including the federal
government and like when there's a woman
at the helm it's gonna be I think it's
gonna be incredible and I think we're
gonna see maybe not the first woman
who's president but maybe the second one
right incredible amounts of progress
made what's interesting about the women
that are running is that Hillary Clinton
and let's say Elizabeth Warren were to
run are both very policy heavy driven
women both of them have certain
personalities that are slightly strong
and maybe could be considered
charismatic
not the men like let's say you were
running against a Marco Rubio are
running against some of those or Chris
Christie those are more personality
driven charismatic leaders through the
women that are could possibly be leaving
those with warns and Hillary Clinton's
are very policy driven this is what
we're gonna get done I don't know the
charismatic woman could win a presidency
right now really right I don't know I
would like to say yes but I think there
needs to be silence here a woman first
to pave the way for women general yeah a
woman can't do jazz hands the way a man
his way to the White House right now
right so is that the irony then with
Elizabeth Warren and Hillary is that
those seem to me to be by far the best
two candidates even though I don't like
the idea of a Clinton legacy or a
Clinton kingship or whatever those seem
to be the best two Democrats but it's
gonna be two women at the top fighting
each other which actually could hurt the
women and then some guy just comes in
and it's the exit how do you feel about
that lady I don't think it's gonna be
like the I don't think it's gonna split
the I'm not worried about it splitting
the vote so much as it's setting a stage
or a precedent for women to be up there
in those debates and for women to have a
place there I would I would be fine with
both of them if it split the votes that
would be a really unfortunate byproduct
of that but yeah having two women I
don't think we can argue as a net
negative yeah all right do we need a
woman in the White House let us know in
the comments right down below